we are going to an experiment that is to give the
tutorial of three the idea is to have
a little bit of homework and small
exercises
a little bit a tentative plan for the tutorial a
little bit the agenda is a presentation
of us a little bit not so much more extensive
some motivation of  graphs, but if they
are here, they are already motivated by
some analysis and exploration, which is going to
be very basic, because that
sometimes requires other tools that are
difficult to tame, detection of
communities, and if in the part that would be
notified, automatic, supervised, we could
say supervised learning.
in the meantime they install things the
internet is not working very well
so if they brought networks and pandas
more or less we are for almost everything is to
continue lean
exit bus because we like it a lot
but they can keep free cauldron and
macro if they want to plot something
but well, I imagine that this
star should be installed because it
is the holy trinity of the country of
art and  it is, but the network is capable, do not
try to install it and we made a link
with data zk that if not we can also
share it in another way, a flash drive or
something there will be a break where there will be
more moments
and then there we can go by adding
the link no  go all together until here
with tutorial the graph yep
I didn't fit everything bar if I put it
chiquitana it reads
tutorial graphs and without space and all
together until yes
well who we are joaquín torres
engineering student is doing
the final project in the albaneses lake
feet and candidates who tell you that they are
tall and I am a conicet researcher
well
leandro in the neighborhood do not hesitate to
ask us to interrupt our whatever you
want
good motivations examples that it makes
sense to think with graphs but the
flat example is also a bit of
notation a bit of  name is a graph
essentially there are two sets a
set of vertices or nodes or
whatever you want to call it points whatever and a
set of edges
lynn just
x in English and other names that are now coming to
my mind but especially
what is a set of edges that says
where they go from does not know that they do
not unite us those edges
can be directed not directed and some
agreements for which side  they go or they can't
join themselves or not but we don't go
then the whole century came out because it's
a bit annoying
I imagine everyone more or less knows
this this nomenclature as an example
I always like to show this what is
he he had he
the  london subway is a hyper-
recon map with has been studied by people
from the organization that obviously shows each
point is one in this case each point is
a station and there is a connection between
one station and the next in the
subway network what is interesting about this  it is that
abstracting the most important information
that is the connectivity within the
station in the other to which I am going in the
case if it has to be kept in
mind that there is an abstraction that there is
a zoom
a vac  there is a distance between
abstraction and reality too but it
is a powerful attraction other possible
examples that there are infinite examples you can
imagine here the network of airports is plotted
and there is an edge between them
if there is a flight from one to another here
the hub is highlighted  from atlanta as it is
one of the ones with the most flights and that
helps us understand how
things that are in space in principle are interconnected,
they do not have to have an
obvious connection
also in this case good
example of twitter which is the only
social network  that can be analyzed unless it
is the owner each point is a user and
here is one there is a list if a user
retweets another this will go a
little higher because it was going to explain
a much clearer example but in this
case it will be  agree it was something about the
trolls that attacked the
conicet investigators if they were paid or not paid it
was an analysis with that and here what it
says what is shown is a detection
of com  units of people who attack and
people who defend like there is a
dynamic and that they are absorbed in the idea
of ​​retweeting many of the examples for
example that you have a network of proteins
in the cells
there is a link between them and a protein
does something that  the other uses it called
interact oma and this also shows
a structure that in principle a
cell is a soup of letters and well
this has
a connectivity of a
structure after they did the
previous tutorial they saw spectral
clustering another way is to grab
points  that are in some space that already
have a distance between them and
one that can put together two graphs very
easily or several but two that are very
easy are from the
closest neighbors one grabs and fixes the three
closest neighbors the five neighbors
whoever you want and connects in that way
only connects one with the closest ones or
establishes a distance of four tells you
good everything that is except a certain
epsilon I'm going to connect it are two
quite direct ways to build a
graph from a metric space in
this one that is fast up to 76 classic island
if one does that as it depends on what
parameters you choose you connect this and
this and sometimes connect between the  two
clusters or not depends on how one goes
modeling that is understood are two
ways of putting together a graph from
data that in principle are
metric or geographical if you want something
more specific I went back
well there are other examples in these
later we share
with the urls
these two there are quite a few more data sets
to play with and try some things well
then a little bit of ways already project
and basic questions if they know the
terminology of graphs 1 or we don't learn
now one can grab dean of
look when how many neighbors they have
this is to count how many people  it's
connected to the node you're in
and that's an example of
a property of a node and I can
do it to everyone  two nodes
and that we are going to see how one can look at
things like the histogram of the size of
that connectivity that measure is called
degree or it is called degree in English the
number of neighbors another thing that
can be done is the
clustering coefficient that is each  Once I have
two neighbors, look at whether they
are connected or not. That gives me an idea
of ​​how interconnected that network is. It is whether
the friends of my friends are my friends
or not.
That depends. That depends on what can be
talked about for each node as well.  and it depends on
the type of graphs, how much is giving
there is also a very famous algorithm
called page rank that you surely
know is the one that gave rise to dhul there is
a psm joke in person that he
heals in a vector car and they became
millionaires since he is here
any graph is proposed and the
size is the pagerank of s/d s/d graphs
I am not going to try to explain very
briefly what one does here is to think
that in each one it puts an agent in a
random node  and at any moment that
agent can go to any of its
neighbors with the same probability it
will go walking to go through that
graph completely at random it is understood
if one does
that many times what you get
is over time that  as I say
different if one puts instead of one puts
many yes many many those are
distributed through the graph and they are
putting together a dynamic of how they move
at random and eventually what ends up
being is places where there are more
likely to be some  and more
probably in others there is some detail
with a regulation factor but it is almost
this
the idea is that this state is the
stationary state of that process that if you do not
reapply that process of
making them walk again they remain essentially
as they were then that to me
how likely it is that it does not end up
being an attractor of those
salazar walkers is understood and that is what they
used the principle to rank pages
as if u  n again long live if you don't go through the
web at random it
eventually falls on the important pages
another is I'm going to apply something that has
nothing to do with it called the central it
and another one of those that one can use
that is one can calculate between
any two nodes the
shortest path between them if the succession
of nodes that goes from one to another and count
for each node now how many times the
shortest path between
any two nodes passes through it was understood is a
bit of a search for the phrase but the  idea is
that then that has an idea of ​​how
important that no is in
network connectivity we are going to see that in a handson
that we do now
to pass look no further
well it
is so heavy
that
the hamsun is going to have several parts
the  grace of the first is that it is something
very empty so that the entire tutorial is
self-contained in fact although the
first thing we do is import things
that anyone who is here
today I am better
at writing
it I don't know how I am
dam  e one
to grow when I do that yes I don't
have to get the
perfect screen there you can see the link
and use it basically as I told you it is
for the tutorial to be self-contained
so the first thing we are going to see is
how to make a graph in python that  the
truth is that it is quite simple
everyone saw the
mason
masum link
now it does look
good
what I was saying is let's see the
basics how to put a graph in python and
what is a kind way to use it
especially considering the things that
we are going  later on
community detection algorithms and
how to use this with machine learning and in
billings so to do
venice with graphs it is good to know how to
save a graph and for that
a library called etoile x is very useful, which is
the  that we are going to be here
so first of all we import are
imports from libraries that everyone here
I suppose knows
and basically we are telling you we are going
to have 10 nodes the nodes are going to have  r
two labels a proportion of 0.3 of
the amount that is going to have that
means that 3 are going to have a label
rise from another label and I put together the
graph I say what my nodes are that
basically I define it as a list and
also  the number of edges that is
a list of pairs then it starts
ready and it is very simple how
a graph is initialized it is simply so that they have
everything here and one can block it by
defining the positions the laws that
I want the colors to have and using
the mad love library live in & well x
I can block a graph
that can be given
here
well
then simple form as we said
there was a proportion of three does not last
labels seven not of another label
are the edges as we defined them
above this is how it can be blocked in a
way  super simple a graph
things to keep in mind is that since I know
where each of the nodes have to go
what the positions or nodes there are
different ways to decide that there are
different m  étodos one way can be
random
another way I am defining this
in line k here we put several ways
in another way it can be to put them in
circles all the nodes in a circle another
way that is the one that is graphic 2 is
the spring layout of spring  layout what it
does is simulate as if there were springs
between my nodes when there are edges in
this way nodes that are connected
to be close together because it has a
spring that does not come out there it is not that they
are not connected to each other they tend to
be further away well it has  this
attractive force this is a good way to see
at a glance which ones are like small
communities which ones don't stay
together and which ones stay separated
from each other
we will see later when
we see examples with more data
later there are other ways like  the
strict spectral layout that what it
does is use the matrix of auto values
of the graph and from those make
the graphs you are simply
changing which  it is commented
by the one that is being used, you can
try all the different ones and see what
differences there are going to give the advantages
that one has over the other depending on
what one wants to observe those
of the graph the grace would be that you
spend trying it now  and
don't ask us anything
but one of the most common ceti data
if you ever worked with
graphs zacarías keyboard that
a graph where each of the nodes
is a person active class of the character
but that declared group of character was
split  in two
then the edges are between the
relationships of the people and one can
see how the people of a generation before and
ended up going to one group or the other of
character we are going to see it to start this
being to its subjects
this is the typical graph where  you
can see the nodes of the people and
how was their relationship between them and in the
next one we are going to do the same but we
say a different color to each of
the clubs that  I ended up having in the end
then, although they were all part of
the same karate club, later there
ended up being two and you see how the
ladies react to each other, the people
who are also in the same club that those who
ended up being different clubs of
character is the  typical example that is
usually used and here we can see it graphed
we see everything conserving it in an object to be
known from newell x
but we may want to study
properties of the nodes so for
that it would be nice to have a cup of
pandas because pandas because it is a
good way  If it were the pandas tutorial,
nothing would apply to you, but it is very useful to
use panda even when you do things.
The machine learning is very nice, the
syntax and the way of using it,
so we will keep the information we
have about these nodes.
in the object of so much of
pandas
originally that we are going to have this
object well the data is tense and it says here
I put honoring a sample of 5 d  and they
are not people and I know in which club they
ended up if they ended up in the one with mister
hyde or or in the other one so having
two communities a priori I only have this
characteristic the nodes but I would
like to have more characteristics the
nodes like for example leandro mentioned
the one of grid  the degree does not, so with a very
little line of code, which is
that line of code, we are going to add the
ir and the country, frank, or the central, and you, which
are the attributes that you mentioned and
tell us when building,
but although it is difficult for me to scroll, we
have not built a data  set a data
frame with all the characteristics of
us the interesting thing here is that each
is not just that little dot that we had in the
original graph but we have the
information in the table of my nodes this
because they put almost everything you know
about imagine  supervised lanín
only look at a table so it is how to
use the information of the graph to be able to
apply some machine lamming method to it
that is basically the talk
how do we combine the graph with a small board
to be able to have better results
when performing supervised match in learning in this case
each one can do super
simple things like graphing the same thing but the
karate club but the color now depends on
the y grid node  so obviously
nodes with more edges are going to be
painted darker and no more
peripherals have lighter colors
this was to visualize a little what
is the importance that each
one of my features is going to have when we
do machine learning things and in
case  they want to present the
code there and making a program is super
simple the quota of pandas is very kind
again so one can make, for
example, one more story of the gray
minutes where one can see how there are
many nodes with very low iris  and
some nodes with higher degree
well
then I am going to leave a little part for
later which is diffusion of the
properties and now we are going  Let's talk a
little more about unsupervised learning
and community detection,
so
how is it going, it
was being for the other side,
not
well then, about community detection,
the basic idea that one wants here is that one
has a lot of nodes, they want us to
very connected
have the same label in common that is to
say that one can find these
dotted lines in my graph that is to say to the
sea what you are seeing here that it may
be the case where each does not only
belong to a community or the case
where a node  belong to several
communities
simultaneously ways to do this
there are a lot
let's see some
like for example well what we said
about detecting communities like for
example a very interesting magnitude
is modularity or modularity it helps us a
lot to be able to find
these communities
the move  area is basically defined
as the number of edges
within the same community with respect to
the number of views  s that there would be if it
were the random distribution, that is,
one expects that in a community there are
many edges within the community and
few towards new ones outside the community,
while if they are
distributed randomly, it would have to have the same
probability, then one can see that
there is a lot of modularity in a clustering
if you have the nodes grouped in a
certain way
then
there are several methods that use this idea
one is the river and newman method that
allows one to have an original graph and
what the algorithm does is to remove
edges like this  until there are no more
edges left, with what criteria are you going to remove the
edges? well, it defines something called
the centrality of an edge, that is,
how many shortest paths pass through an
edge if an edge connects two
communities, that is, places one day many
us one side many new  the other and an
edge of them joins all the nodes to
go to the nodes they take their minimum path
they will have to go through that list
then  We can say that this list is going
to have a great centrality, so
what does the method do? It
calculates the centrality of
all the edges step by step and eliminates the edge
with the greatest centrality. In this way, it
extracts and one has a program
where  you can go well I want as many
communities and you can fix it
is the cut that one makes and thus obtain
the communities
another method can be the wine method
which is an interactive method where it is
initialized with a lot of communities
one for each node all the  nodes have
as their own community they are alone and
the trick is to connect them that is to say
at each step of the iteration it is not
yet associated with the community of some of its
neighbors and it is checked if this increases the
modularity this is done many times it
is found out  be determining if
the modularity is increased until they converge at the
moment they converge one can say
that they have already armed their communities
but we say this but now we are going
to  see a practical example in particular
we are going to be working with a data set
of bibliographic citations I don't know how many
here read the summary of the talk or
simply came because there was a
talk but what
it said is we are going to work with up to
seven bibliographic citations that is  a
paper is a node and is connected to
another paper if they cite each other then
one can assume that all
economics papers are highly
cited but they will rarely cite
molecular biology papers then
one can understand what the topic is  of a
paper simply because of the connectivity
that exists in itself
no no no one quoted the other if it is directed it
is a graph directed to this we are
going to treat it as if it were not
directed by gas for practical purposes
then it will change but it does not change as much and
if it is  only if one side exists we
consider the edge does not have to
exist both ran into a matter
of time we do not usually get that
well there are other methods that are going to be
explain joaquín
well we are going to see two more methods now
to be able to divide our communities
punctually the euro for jason it is a
fairly simple method we achieve
so much complexity but this method of
linear order development with which it is
quite good later we are going to see a
little that the  times even in a
relatively small graph it is
medium as there are things that can go
wrong but it is not millions of new things
like that we are
going to see that there is
quite a big difference in a good sense of
passion it is a method too
it finds communities and as you can see
basically part of the first step in the
iteration where each node is
also a community and from that it is going to
take in each iteration an
edition rule for each one the rule is
each node is going to say that if there is a
majority community in my neighbors I
'm going to become that community it's fine
if I have, for example, three neighbors who
are from mouth and one neighbor who  It's from the river,
now I'm from the mouth, it's understood,
so the idea would be for release,
I'm going to make a pass through all the
knots applying that decision rule, the
order is random
[Music]
that once they converge because there
comes a point that there is no  more
possible pressures or changes a solution is reached it
's super simple it works well
in some houses it can fail an
interesting thing about this method is that
we can use it in this way where
we find communities without any
prior knowledge we can also
make it semi-supervised this
comes to  be the following if we have
some new classifieds in the graph
we can take those as
initial initial communities also then
we apply the diffusion that is like the
radiation that I just explained to you for
the graph and we are going to find to which of
those classes the rest of the nodes belong
so we have a case of
semi-supervised semi-learning because we
don't have like a vision of tra  ining and
testing and we have a case in which
some are, a few are with law bills
and the rest of the majority are not, and we want to
see what we can find with that,
another case is that they do spectral,
I understand that they saw it, well, I imagine that
almost all of them were  for the previous one
it
wasn't the river because I didn't understand the
ghost press spectral so it's
like a ghost I didn't understand
thanks
I don't have many lights because well one
fundamental thing for graphs is
fundamental but very interesting and well
now we're going it
's the beach no  of a graph it's fine it's
a matrix it
has its own very interesting it's the
matrix the plastia na of matter the
degrees that is to say it's a square matrix
where
each diagonal element we're going to put the
degree of senator as well and it's going to be
the matrix  of adjacency
alternatively because we see that it can
be a matrix of weights if we have a
directed graph then an
affinity matrix if we do not have a graph but
we want to use it anyway because  he picks us up
in the plaza no and similar things it's
called the plastia no because as a certain
analogy with the plastia that we knew
from mathematics,
a classic high school subject,
then
we have various forms a sixth called
the combinatorial plaza and so on, but it was worth it
if they want to use it, they are also  valid
these are
still the same with a
little hat is the neighbor of a which
becomes the identity matrix more or less a
depends on how they use it but basically
something very similar and it also works
because we would use one instead of another for
some properties
For example, that no longer changes the norm,
so if we want to use it to
propagate properties, because of style it
can be more subtle or because it
scales the vectors for us
and again a very interesting thing about
this is precisely to see the spectrum or the
auto  vectors and auto values ​​of this
matrix
has many properties is like aloe
vera and basically the idea would be that
for example
in principle the  first if one
orders them from less significant or more
significant let's say auto values
from the smallest to the
largest the first you always go third
for a simple property of the matrix
that can be seen by females and they do
the counting is the one that that  it means
but after if the second
self value is also negative roster
is also zero it means that the graph
is our only link with which
simply well from a matrix you can
start to analyze it as a structure
of graphs
and then the first self value does not
the smallest but not null 1 obviously has a
social win self and if one
assigns to each of the nodes the
element of that vector self, you can
find a fairly good and
fairly cheap solution to the problem of the case of
the
most disperse cut  of graphs the cut comes to
be this of cutting a graph that is to say
cut the edges to divide it in two
where I do it so that I do not separate
many relations  So, if I do
that method, let's say tell each
to each you did not assign an element that you see
to its corresponding one, you think it
belongs to it
in that car vector and I ordered them to
find a good cut for you can
see the backgrounds now they showed for
examples
so that they are spectral bin astro
basically this idea we calculate the
chapters auto vectors build the matrix
let's see with those with the high vectors and
basically we are going to represent each point
with its k
numbers of the actor cars and we have
that auto vectors each point is going to  have
its
the corresponding auto vector 1 2 and
3 in this case we have 3 so the one that
each node is going to be in was 3 and then
we use that because because the idea is
that we can represent each node
as a point in a space  and it is going to be
well divided by the property of that of
the eigenvectors
that we do use space that in
theory is much simpler than doing
the problem of the communities we can
have  do it with a linear method, for example, it
summons nearest neighbors and
we assign the 'clusters' to the vertices
and I have an example, so
basically I have the affinities,
that is, how much a new one looks like each
node and here they are ordered in any
way, let's say we see  that there are obviously
instructions that are possibly
but there are sections that are more
illuminated than others with which they are
like parts of the graph or nodes that are
more similar to each other
and once we order the nodes
based on the value that corresponds to them in the
first car vector with non-null self value we are
going to find that it is divided with
which we can find two communities
there we have like two for since
illuminated and if one were to say well
that two communities you recommend me to
find let's say where it cut to I would say
short for here  for example you can see
this I had a little it's time
that
and here I have the notebook
thanks
so
how do we see a part of the part of two
of  communities section and we make the
traditional amounts we would make an
amount plus 2 actually one that
is not as if you are important because it
does not appear but if they import it like that it
does appear
and then the other is community that is
implemented le bain and if not  they have
commented on this line and they execute it and it
should appear if they use linux and if they don't
use linux I can't do more
today it's good
differential and well then we use the
cora I'm going to make a type of graph
like the one we mentioned before the d
the of  Basically we have
about 3,000 nodes, that is, 3,000 papers
with 5,000 relationships, that is, 5,000 citations,
and
then each node has attributes
that they are going to give later, which
refers to the types of words that are
in that paper, such
as the previous things
and  it presumes you a function of one of those
communities that we are going to see now of
demand that we have for example volume
that took 6 seconds that is quite
good the truth but for example if you
free for it they have taken much
less imagine that this is a graph of
three thousand new ones so this one in a graph
of 30,000 you see it is not linear when it
grows unlike law preparation
with which it will not be say ten times
more but it will be  a little worse would be 20
or 30 challenges, that
's fine, so what I did here
was, for example,
analyze in principle to run how well
I did before and also add,
for example, in principle once I
find that they run, let's say
the method is run  with what they see,
one can analyze well that they look for a
community it was found then in
principle you have to see well clearly to
see the majority and minority community you
have to give, for example, the
size of the number of nodes in each
community so a simple bar plot says clearly
then  you can see each little
bar is one is a community the
height is the number of nodes with
which we are going to see that more or less around here you are
going to see that these are communities that
are  irrelevant means in fact if they
made a plot of the graph they will see that
most likely they are papers that have
few citations or that the
rest are not related when they are far away and in fact they
are in unconnected parts of graphs
so this time they would not be interested in
analyzing this  part this function that I put together
does several things maybe
too many but that's how I am
then basically takes the mapping
basically of each node to the community
takes graphs the positions I
did something here before we talked about that
we have several methods to find
the positions of  the nodes
I ran everything without any media something
good so what happened was to raise the
graph in chief and run a different rhythm
and more force of the two which was
quite good so I saved the
positions in a csb raise that which is
what  what I did up here and save that
simply so that it can be seen more or
less well let's say
then even the histogram another thing
that the metrics do the americas  s
takes a little longer than
and also less
t
because then the metrics we have
are basically
the cover to 2 that we saw before the
performance changes it the modularity of
louvain is interesting let's say the plugin
optimizes that mobility on time it is
interesting to see how the rest not like  the
rest works with that modular and although they
don't optimize it directly and they can
do that if they want to play with this it
costs it works they can do that they have
several parameters for that
and that they have let's say all the
results here for example is the
situation graph with basically each
color is  a cluster like here there are 100 there are
100 elements what they can do is for
example put 19 groups this what they are going
to do is bring communities together then there
is the community that has like all
those who were in small communities and
these are the largest communities  and
that they have a painted graph that
basically is the communities
here we are other methods if you want to see
and basic  mind that
later they can do interesting things
obviously if they have, for example
, class information they can see if the
communities contribute information to the
classes they can make a metric, for
example, of gain information, non-
entropy, multive entropy things like
that, so it is very interesting if they also have
information on  classes or features to be
able to do
that right
now and we now enter the final stretch of the
tutorial the idea is to explain a little more
we are going to go to the third
part of the notebook and then yes,
we ask more questions and try to
move forward  This part, then, in a
typical type of scenario, as I comment
on supervised learning, does not have a
column and a table and a column that it
wants to predict based on the others
and I do not know if they more or less grab the
favorite, throw a fit at it and
then that's it
What we want to tell now is what happens
if our table is the nodes of a
graph, that is, I have one in each row,
I have some p  properties are I have
columns that are properties each row
I also know connections between them yes
how can I use that
there are some here we put a paper that
tells a very clear example very clear
for biologists they realized
that there were relationships between genes
when they were  they expressed at the same time
and what they realized is that they
wanted to predict a certain property,
I think that this case of whether the mutations are
carcinogenic or not, and it was much better
if they also considered with whom
those genes connected, let's just say the
information that it was that  gen hasn't
reached it but I didn't even see
the connected version
well they propose something but half by
pedal then there are other approaches
where one
broadcasts the evenings that one knows and there is
a kind of regression of neighbors but
graph version now what happens when
you have both if you have because in
many cases of the networks that are as an
example one has only the
connectivity  ad or you have the tablet and you don't
have political data but when
you want I don't have things like I can
use it well one option is to add
columns to the table which is a bit
like with what fede explained you do
one you have the table you don't have  you can
add columns that come from the graph
the page rank the one in gray the centrality
all questions that have to do with
how that node is in and how it is immersed
between neighbors how many neighbors it has how
those neighbors are related the clusterin
central confusion now another thing that
I can do is grab a variable that
I know and bring me the one from the neighbors
too, so it
is possible, like spreading,
returning to the placid no and reusing that
idea
if I grab
saw with making a dilution like there
is the coffee, the milk or the heat when
one heats up something like
everything around it begins to heat up well
one can mount a discrete version of
that with the square no of the graph and from
there perhaps it is also the no  name of the square
of the graph one grabs the matrix of the
plasty no and grabs it a function that
knows during all the in all the
nodes that is a column of the table and
multiplies it by that matrix and what it has
is an averaged version of  the neighbors
how each node distributed what it had
to its neighbors is understood then for
example if I am one I am in a
magnificent corporation that wants to
predict how much they go to people and knows
who is friends with who
can use the hypothesis that people
who are friends with people with money have
money and people who are friends with people
with little money have little money so
if you know something about how some
socioeconomic variable can be averaged
for friends you understand or I don't know I want to
predict if someone is going to  buy something
good let's say I know the income
that is how I'm going to buy a
good racing car capable he doesn't have that much
money but if there is money around him it
's because it's about taxes and in reality
it has a higher status than it seems, no,
so that that variable affects me in
anything, I want to predict that
I think it has an influence and that it is a
variable that responds not only to a node
but to its environment, you can use this
technique and it is a bit  what we want to show you
is like the main course if you
want this because we are going to get the other one
but well it remains in the notebook
so that
those who code level can play then but
what is also there
and now I am going to tell you an example of
twitter  what he did and then we go to the
third part of the nothing
good we are going to talk a little about twitter
because it sells and people are usually
interested in that and let it be twitter we add
politics to it we are going to make it a little more
interesting
I don't know if everyone here is from  argentina but
in 2017 there were elections in our country
in particular or senator elections
in buenos aires prediction where
there were many candidates among them
was cristina fernández de kirchner
for the official  ism was esteban
bullrich for change we were also
candidates massa and randazzo remember
that at this moment the mass is healthier
because it is in the same party because that will
be later so without spoilers what
we did was download tweets in spanish
in argentina and that  Mention some of
the candidates or Macri or Abidal to
ask from the governor of the
province of Buenos Aires because we
consider that they are important and
thank you to see a little how
people interact in this social network
so first of all you can make a
graph as they mentioned  where each
node is a user and each edge is
ages and a user retweet me to another
user
then using boss 1 you can block it
and show nodes very close if they were
held a lot and very far away if there was
no connection between them then one
here can see it  for the ace step that are the
primaries and also for the definitive elections
what is the first thing that one observes well
that there are two pel  big ots what does it
mean there are two communities that concentrate
the largest number of users who talk a
lot to each other and talk a little with each
other as with the other community in other
words this is the
graphic representation of the crack
basically it is people who talk to us between
If he talks a lot with people who think
exactly the same,
there are two large communities,
one represents users who are from
let's change, others to citizen unity,
which today would be everyone, and later also
some veins passed by smaller communities,
such as this one, which is of great
randazo that it has  his own community,
well away from us, this mass is
also green, it is people who speak exclusively about Macri,
but management issues of
Macri because, in addition to being an
electoral moment, he is President, so there are
day-to-day things that are also
tweeted, it is to form a separate community
and  Basically, there are these two
large communities, these small nodes
with a lot of users behind them, they are
people who  ue was famous for a day because it
had a tweet the worst one became famous for
example there it is and one that cristina
kirchner has posted I am in mardel and she
retweets you are in mardel and name the
silver because the silver steals it from you
then it became very viral  that tweet and he
put together as his little mini community
but the interesting thing here is that good
to start in the steps we have all
these communities but in the
definitive ones we see a difference
number one the users of the
mass community are less when those are no longer there
then  one can consider well I
have a lot of users I have data
on what these users talk about
I can want to know how they
change communities that is to say try to detect
pancakes people who were in a
community and then said no good in the
definitive ones we are going to support  another
then first of all we see the
percentages for the
justicialista party is that of rounds or where
a large flow to other communities which
qua  It is to be expected in an election for
senator where only among the people for
the majority and the first minority,
so coming out third fourth in an
election does not contribute anything
and the majority of the people are usually in
a citizen and we change so one
can  think well we are going to apply
everything we saw about I have a graph that is to say
I have all this network that we had seen
before but I also have a table that
is this table well I have the users
to each one of my little people and I have a
lot of characteristics that  I can
measure from the graph the dir and the
page rank, the clustering coefficient,
etc. Also to this we add a
lot of things that I am not going to put much
emphasis on now, in lp of
natural language processing of the tweets
to know if they are  speaking in favor of they
would do another's favor the feeling the
topic they were talking about they are
talking about more that they are talking about
santiago maldonado what topics are they
discussing
and everything  this to predict had
jumped from the community they had not been created
and what I can say positive is
the following graph here we have the
out curves that will be
great the
straighter the better the diagonal line
represents a random classifier that
says it is  bread that I did not pillar anything
totally tasty and we have several
models that we were testing first the
simple model where we said well if
you were in the community of randazo
massa you changed community not the punk one and
even in the final destructions
that has a better score  that random
but not very good
but then we have another two other
three models that are ex just
gradient-powered trees one
trained only with the columns that
dam the text of in lp and text
mining others only with the columns that
we got from  of the analysis of
graphs and another with everything we are going to put
all the columns to see what is
given and we can see that the subject is not so
good at  time to classify how you
can know how to get involved with some
dependents of the graph why is this happening
because they think this can happen you have
to see the graph it is more important than
the
good topic in particular it turns out that the country
is now very important the file
is important it is very important for  know
if someone is a panicer or not because
both cristina and the one who retweets
cristina or tweets about it generally talk about the same
topic so the topic is not
so decisive to say where
you stand but how important you are
on the radio if that is a new  very
peripheral you are going to have more chances of
changing the community than if it is a new
central axis within a community
then that in the first place then one
if the text files also
serve you as for example we saw that if
you talk about santiago maldonado for example
already  you have made a decision about which
community to belong to and in which you
talk about how economically it can be that you
change from a community  community to another, this in
case there is any political interest, well,
I am not talking about Santiago Maldonado, he is talking about the
economy, which is what makes these
undecided come to a certain community,
well, this is a bit about 2017,
but as you have already seen, the parties that
were there  some are here now others got
together so we are going to talk about 2019
in 2019 this is about the week where
the steps were taken the elections
happened where we lowered a lot of names of
the candidates in the province of Buenos
Aires at the national level to deputies to
senators  to legislators, people who
hold media positions within politics
or who, although they are not a candidate
like Carrió, are still part of the
political discussion.
that we are going to use now in the
example that is why I am telling you
we have a million and a half tweets more
than a million retweets which is what
allows us to have the aris  tas and
from this we have more than 200,000
nodes we are just working with 2000
with the times and you are two orders of
magnitude more that allows us to build this
network
then in this network again that
we see well there are two groups
because the crack is still
yellow then  the official is
in blue and in light blue are the
opponents, which would be all of them,
and they are painted in two colors, one is the
community because when we ran
the wine method, it detected it as if they
were two communities that are very
close in dark blue, it would be the people
who  they are not official accounts
while in the celestial community there are all
the official accounts of the
fernández list and obviously a lot of
users that we are
the candidates
the list of candidates and it was already and they
were all in this and that is by hand
because they are  the number of candidates is not that
many just like
how
here there are a lot of users who are
candidates and there are a lot of users
who are not  Candidates but they are but there
are no candidates in this
community that is why we call them candidates for
more than they would also be candidates and people
think that these little dots here
these are users if all this
is painted there is a lot
these are users who realize that  the
one that no one repeats and no one continues well
people that no one repeats it is
interesting things that one can
analyze like this with the naked eye of the
graph if you are interested is
the left front is much
closer to being opposition to change than to
All
Gómez Centurión and Expert are in
the middle but it is closer to
Let's
change Fernández
Lavagna
There is not
a little interpretation that can be
made of that is that voters are not
usually people who are on Twitter a lot because of
their demographics
and one last detail  which can also
be interesting is that there are two
communities here and they continue for macri there
are also two communities the yellow one
is well centered but in  where
because since two candidates but the one who
are people are usually more points than a
well-closed and well-armed community that
interacts a lot with each other, which
raises a difference between the two
and in color detail in case you want to see
these are data from before  of the
elections in parentheses they have the
percentages that they got in the
final elections the others are the
number of users percentage that they
have with respect to the rest
it usually does quite well I do not
mean that this replaces the surveys
because each one does not take into account
margin of error  nor how is the demographics,
but when taking into account two orders of
magnitude more than any
national survey that has been carried out, it can be seen
that at least the big parties do
quite well, so this is
a bit of the data set that we are going to analyze
the funny thing is that we analyze it
well
to change
there is
a detail first of all in part 1
at the end of everything if you want to see they have
codes  go super simple to
spread properties among your new neighbors
and in the commented part you can
change if you want it to be first neighbors
to second neighbors to third neighbors to
fifth neighbors to whom two neighbors
know anything we do not recommend it
but save properties from  first
seconds or third neighbors is usually
quite useful
well now having said that we are going
to go down a bit and we are going to see
a bit of the implementation of all this
here I am not passing you the graph itself
I am going to pass you a table she has
calculated things  of the graph why is
this because it usually takes 20 minutes and
half an hour to calculate the detection of
communities remember that the
wine method has time in the ob n and when
we are dealing with more than 200,000 nodes it
takes a little time and for this tutorial
it was not practical to say  well we wait 20
minutes yes and then we continue
so that they basically have the
super simple code and can replicate it in
whatever  any of your examples first
import things between them
dsk lean exists because it exists because it
exists it is a machine learning model it
proved to have very good
results for the entire structure
as well as a table and for attributes that are
heterogeneous among themselves so it is usually
simple it usually gives  better results not
always sometimes always a
logistic regression can beat them but it depends a
lot but it usually has good results
so we start by importing our
user data where we have good
user air which is a
random number to identify each of
our users
we have  the playball which is the name
they keep on twitter if
we have a lot more
metadata from what is the official name
when they retweeted for this
easy example we are going to throw a lot of things
like geolocation etc.
we are going to have six columns that  the
most important topics are what was
talked about
in particular  ular the topic 0 represents that there was
so much talk about vidal in the tweets
of that person
cluster is with the wine method that
we saw before is a little while where
depending on the number that is distributed it is
a community or belongs to another here
we are going to treat it as  a single column
that has different numbers that
can vary, I think, from 0 to 13, but
if not, something that can be quite good
is to use a hotton coding with easy
variables to be able to have many
columns, so perhaps the model
understands the different communities better
especially thinking that the community is
perhaps not the one that comes after
community 2 but that they are simply two
separate communities and it has a number
after the other, simple because we have
to give it a name but it is not that
this order represents something, then there is
other characteristics such as the
centrality of the pagerank etc.
you can see it there then
we are going to build we are going to separate it into 33
vam  We are going to train it with one using cross
validation and from that we are going to see
that our models are also going to do it by
seeing zoophilia feature
files that are text,
we are going to do a hyper-
parameter exploration with randomized and in truth it
ends up like returning, it does not  we did it because
we wanted it to run very fast that's why
we said try only two combinations
but thank you that you put in
a much higher number and that you already
have the complete distribution of
different ones and prepare meters to
find a good combination that
really gives you  optimal results
this is quite good especially to
add that little difference in the
score that is sometimes so difficult to
achieve and with a couple of lines of
code sometimes it is enough
well we are going to have our random
search lipper parameters we adjust it
with training parameters  of the test and
we are going to want to know what our
best model is, train it and test it,
then our first case
e  s simply with text data as
if we had not seen the graph
basically we just look at users we
see what they talk about and we want to predict if they are going
to talk about vidal or not they are going to talk about
vidal we saw about other topics he is
also talking about economy he is
also talking about  Macri is also talking about Christina, he
is talking about corruption
of the evaluation economy, well, in addition
to these cases, he is talking about video,
that is not the question we ask the model,
and the truth is that when we look at the out, the
score of the area under the curve is
quite bad.  because it gives 0.50 102 and
we want to round it up in a nice way
which is basically saying you are
doing it randomly or it is not doing
much better than something random
but well we can later
want to train it
well that is having seen this class and
not knowing what it calculates from  precision that
all these features are useful
so having done that and putting
all the columns of our data
set
here we can  s obtain a much higher score
than we are going to see now in this photo
I just want to tell you that we
are also doing it with in this other case
with only graph data and not text
as we have the three models only text
only graph igraph and text  speaking of
the features with which we train the
model,
from that we can pilot
our rock curves as we had
done before where we have
zoom save
[Music]
is then what we can
basically see is
when the mouse pointer comes
we have several curves  how far they can
think that they are 2
that because it is because as we had said
with training only with the text that is
the green line it is almost random
so the random that was the diagonal
the black line is almost invisible
because it is slightly covered
by the  green line this what does it mean
that our text model is lousy
that simple
then we have the model that was
trained only with features of the graph the
model that was trained only with
graph tokens is the blue curve
what this tells us is there is a lot of
information there is basically a lot
of information that is stored in
what the graph is like what community the
user is in to say what topic  is
speaking and there is a lot of
information there and then when
we combine both we have the red curve which is
obviously the one with the best score if
it were not the one that determines the best score what to
say here we did it wrong because having a
couple more columns usually gives better
results  and from that we got
the red curve
one can plot the importance of
each of our attributes
ok well well the last idea I wanted to
tell you is the most important column is
the page rank which is the graph so it is
important in part 4 that  as
we started a little late maybe no not
of the time we have some examples of
notebook that basically how to calculate
in beijing with nodes
let's go here right away we are
any question and basically it
allows us to have a representation in
lower dimensionality and mathematics that
is one of its neighbors
also
well
I don't know if you listened I don't know when you
were practicing with these things
the funny thing would be the one that you
can roast with the data set  tail
with the data certainties that we gave you
we tell you the features we gave you the
edges it would be good if you could
apply the same thing to this other data set
especially to fix ideas and not that
in something that they told me once but that
of truth  it is a tool that
can help you in your day to day life if you work
with
imagine learning graphs so if you have
any questions we will be going
through your computers any questions
you have tell us and if you do not have the
part I did not have and in billings with graphs
in the  notebook and on devices
and